it is here the budget-friendly 40 series
card with all the newest Ray tracing
technology the question is is the 4060
your next card cue the intro sequence
[Music]
[Applause]
Asus has kindly barred as one of their
brand new RTX 4060 duoc cards to find
out whether we can actually justify that
300 MSRP first things first we need to
get it out of the box this is a nice
looking card it's dual fan and only two
slots thick which makes it a perfectly
good option for smaller cases or mini
ITX builds it's got some cool
see-through accents which I like and a
nice looking back plate although you
don't get any RGB as for power it only
needs one eight pin and about a 650 watt
power supply should be more than enough
juice to run it so now let's talk
performance my biggest concern going in
definitely has to be vram a few years
ago 8 gigabytes was more than enough but
that's not really the case anymore
especially with how large and demanding
open world games are getting the 4016
does at least support the newest dlss
which it heavily relies on without it
the gaming experience is going going to
be pretty limited even in 1080P
especially if you want to play newer
games and get decent FPS while having
all your settings maxed out like in
cyberpunk for example we saw an FPS of
32 with Max settings and Ray tracing
enabled but dlases boosted that to a
respectable 55 frames per seconds when
turned on in more competitive titles
we're getting all the frames you can
matters more than how it looks turning
off Ray tracing and lowering some of the
settings should be enough to get you to
that sweet spot of 144. in fortnite this
made a difference of almost 50 frames
taking it from around 50 frames per
second on Mac settings and Ray tracing
enabled to about 100 frames per second
on high settings with the rate racing
off in Modern Warfare 2 we saw around
105 frames per second on ultra settings
which jumped to around 142 frames per
seconds just by turning the LSS on
during the last week I asked all of my
subscribers whether they're more
interested in 1440p results or 1080p
results and unfortunately I don't think
1440p is is an option to look at
considering what we got with the 1080p
results on its own if you're looking to
gaming 1440p or above the 4060 isn't
gonna be for you especially if you want
anything near to decent frames or good
quality the next thing I'm always very
interested in is the cooling and this
car did run relatively cool throughout
testing especially considering it's a
two fan card I think the lower TDP on
these newer cards make sure that thermal
throttling shouldn't be a problem Asus
also added a dual bios on this card so
we could easily switch it into gaming
mode for some extra cooling power just
in case the highest temperatures we saw
was about 70 degrees Celsius in normal
gaming if you're looking for a bit more
detailed rundown of what this car can do
I'd recommend take out gamers nexus's
videos next or even Linus Tech tips for
a bit more of a detailed breakdown so in
the end it all comes down to do I think
it's worth picking up the 4060 well it
actually really depends if you're
starting a new Bolt from scratch where
you're looking at a brand new
budget-friendly option then yes this
isn't a bad call but if you already have
a GPU especially if it's something like
a 30 60 or even better then probably not
I would recommend holding on to your
card for a few more months saving up a
little bit longer for the 4070. the
slide jump you'll see in performance
from the previous generation 3060
doesn't justify the investment I really
feel that Nvidia could have given us a
little bit more especially at the price
and compared to the previous generations
but that's just my opinion I hope you
have a great day and if you like the
content remember to subscribe anyways
Cheerios until the next one bye
[Music]